sí
ahora llegó el momento de pensar en cómo
recrear la variación natural de forma
digital
hola chicas ya regresé traje como
siempre unos cuantos cambios al paquete
de las piernas y pensé que querían verlo
estábamos a punto de empezar a hablar
sobre los detalles de la piel y las
escamas gracias tía de nada muy buena
suerte gracias aquí podemos ver que
agrego un patrón de referencia para la
piel y las escamas me recuerda la
variación que vemos en las nubes
aquí hay ambas cosas variación de
colores de verde amarillo y también
variación de brillo de oscuro a claro y
observa que la piel tiene un patrón
distinto al de las escamas se ve más
suave y más oscuro para empezar
simplifiquemos nuestro problema primero
enfoquémonos en una sola escama imagina
que cortamos una tira delegada de esta
forma como una tira de pintura ahora
podemos ver mejor la variación fluye de
verde oscuro a verde claro ahora su
trabajo es representar esto de forma
matemática en la computadora una tira de
pintura es representada como una
sucesión de celdas de colores o píxeles
y el color de cada pixel puede variar de
verde oscuro a verde claro como una tira
de pintura muy larga y lo que queremos
expresar es la variación del brillo
ayuda mucho pensar en esto como una
gráfica en 2b donde el eje de las x es
la posición en la tira de color y el eje
de las yes representa el brillo del
color en este momento todos los colores
son el mismo porque tenemos una línea
plana no hay variación y podemos ajustar
aquí el color base y la línea está
construida con muchos puntos de control
si los jalamos hacia arriba se vuelve
una región más brillante y si los
jalamos hacia abajo se vuelve más oscura
a esto le llamamos una función lineal
por partes genial y observa qué sucede
si dispersamos aleatoriamente estos
puntos esto se está acercando a lo que
queremos pero un problema con este
método es que las transiciones tienen
una frontera muy definida
cierto pero podemos arreglar eso
suavizando esta colección de líneas eso
se hace usando el deslizador de
subdivisiones ya estudiamos cómo
funciona el algoritmo de subdivisión en
la lección de modelado de personajes
pero todo lo que necesita saber es que
este deslizador define que tanto lo
suavizamos y que provoca estas
transiciones graduales manipulando el
color base la posición de los puntos
podemos generar todo un rango de
patrones geniales
ahora puedes ponerte a jugar con esto en
el próximo ejercicio tu trabajo es crear
un patrón igual al que te vamos a dar
seleccionando el color inicial correcto
y construyendo la curva 2d que define la
variación de brillo adecuada en este
ejemplo estamos usando la curva para
controlar el brillo pero qué otras cosas
podemos controlar con una curva como
ésta podemos controlar muchas cosas con
este tipo de curvas pero un ejemplo
divertido son las alas de los insectos
como las libélulas o los saltamontes
tenemos un montón de esos en el viaje de
arlo pero también en otras películas
como en bichos y bueno a lo largo del
ala termina y variación de transparencia
color la calidad de iluminación todos
estos los podemos controlar con curvas
como estas